[Musique]
avant de faire une maîtrise en musique
et un doctorat en anthropologie le cri
robert falcon wallet a connu la misère
il avait vécu plusieurs mois dans la rue
avec sa mère aujourd'hui il représente
un décompte et les plus pauvres du
canada avec 1400 sans abri plus de la
moitié sont de jeunes autochtones qui
sortent du système de la protection de
l'enfance les enfants sont vus comme un
réseau naturel en des jeux toujours des
enfants sont les plus importants mais
ils sont importants pour raison qu'il
rapporte l'argent pour le député la
protection de la jeunesse est devenue
une industrie les incitatifs financiers
ont un effet pervers
chaque maillon du système a été ré a
gonflé sa clientèle et a exagéré la
gravité des cas résultat les diagnostics
se multiplient car plus un enfant est
médicamenté plus la famille d'accueil
--l'agence s'enrichissent la famille de
l'enfant des mains et problème et
comportement est traumatisée et qu à pas
content d'être resté avec nous autres
avec ses parents à faire évaluer par un
cyclone
un problème de moteur sans le patron des
services à l'enfant et à la famille du
manitoba admet d'emblée les ratés du
système de ce sont des hectares
[Musique]
tamara c'est très bien qui est le
sous-ministre rogers il préside l agence
de winnipeg qui avait la responsabilité
de ses enfants durant leur première
année en foyer d'accueil qui ça des
blancs
vos enfants nous appartient aurait dit
le sous ministre
impossible de vérifier cet échange mais
il est conforme à la culture
d'entreprise qui ne croient pas en la
réhabilitation
les maires qui ont des enfants dans le
système n'ont pas eu droit à une seconde
chance
tamara malcom début de ces journées avec
sa fille de sept ans qui nie à
surprendre
l'enfant est élevé dans une grande
maison par des parents aimants qui lui
offre tout ce dont elle peut rêver mais
ne filtre a quand même pu aboutir en
foyer d'accueil ses frères est encore
dans le système
sa mère est automatiquement jugée
incompétente sisters ou manitoba l'an
dernier 400 bébés autochtones ont été
arrachés à leur mère de la naissance la
maman est jugée incapable soit parce
qu'elle a été élevée en famille
d'accueil ou parce qu'elle a déjà un
enfant dans le système un bébé alors d'
une alerte est émise dès qu'une de ses
femmes devient enceinte de racisme aussi
qui soutient tout ce système là même si
c'est pas ces quads au ses dépenses et
nos actes acteurs prise de crise trois
mêmes parce qu'on a déjà fait des
pensionnats autochtones
on a fait enlever des enfants dans les
années 60 et on continue aujourd'hui
le sous ministre admet aisément les
failles du système sont connus depuis
longtemps
mais les réformes tardent et quand il
s'agit de corriger le tir dans des cas
précis on ne reconnaît aucune erreur
iron man kong et les femmes autochtones
brisé tamara s'est reconstruite en se
branchant sur sa culture en passant de
longues heures à fabriquer des bijoux de
perles
[Musique]
elle a transformé sa passion en
entreprise rentable de sa petite
boutique au nord de l'ontario
elle vend des perles partout au canada
hoffman
mais cette femme devenue un modèle est
un leader dans sa communauté continuent
d'échouer le test de la dpj manitobaine
et pour cause
le kiwi camara poursuit désormais le
gouvernement du manitoba pour obtenir la
garde de ses deux plus jeunes qui ont
disputé en ce combat acharné de leur
mère c'est la lueur au bout du tunnel
qui permet aux garçons de ne pas sombrer
cette équipe qui part en nous
vous
nous
[Musique]
quand même sophie on a des bonnes
nouvelles parce que depuis votre
tournage avec tamara il ya eu quand même
des développements oui alors deux
semaines après notre tournage il ya eu
un déblocage complètement inattendu dans
le dossier de son fils de 15 ans ça
c'est celui qu'on entend à la toute fin
du reportage donc tamara a annoncé sur
les réseaux sociaux
monfils revient à la maison pour de bon
cela fait dix ans que j'attends ce
moment de voir mon fils grandir sous le
manteau alors imaginez la joie qu'elle a
dû ressentir ce jour là mais son bonheur
s'est un peu estompée depuis parce que
l'adolescent est toujours sous la
tutelle du gouvernement du manitoba
elle ne sait pas quand est-ce qu'elle va
retrouver son droit parental et elle a
un peu l'impression qu'on continue de
vouloir la prendre en défaut comme on le
fait pendant dix ans surtout que son
plus jeune celui qui a 10 ans est lui
toujours en famille d'accueil à winnipeg
donc c'est une grande victoire pour elle
mais son combat n'est pas terminé